my name is rosemary i'm a food scientist
[Music]
and today we're going to be talking
about each and every plant-based milk
[Music]
first up almond milk
almond milk has been around for
centuries it's first referenced in
baghdadi cookbooks as well as medieval
european cookbooks in the 14th century
it's very neutral it's slightly thinner
than some of the other plant-based milks
one of the benefits of almond milk is
it's high in alpha-tocopherol or vitamin
e it's also slightly lower in protein
and it's lower in carbohydrates as well
most of the almonds that we consume in
north america come from california
california does not have a lot of water
almonds take up a lot of land space and
they require quite a lot of water as
irrigation in order for the plants to
grow and proliferate so that is a
environmental impact that's very
significant almond milk can separate in
your coffee and that's because when you
put it in a really acidic environment
like coffee it just forms these small
particles at really high heat with low
acidity which is exactly what you have
when you have a cup of coffee
oat milk is the new milk on the market
oat milk is another super popular
plant-based milk and it's very easy to
make at home all you need are rolled
oats some very icy cold water because
the oats will start to gelatinize it's a
chemical process where the bonds between
the starch molecules start to break they
open and allow water in we don't want
that with our oat milk because that's
how it gets slimy and we're going to get
as much of the oats as possible because
that's where all the flavor the fiber
some of the protein
and the beta glucans that we really want
for our good health to come out you want
to use rolled oats and not whole groats
or instant because the instant have some
chemicals added to them that make them
really porous so they're not quite as
nutrient dense as the straight slow
cooked rolled oats it's really only been
around since the 1990s it's based on a
grain oatmeal which has known health
benefits let's see how oat milk made at
home is going to froth
this is frothing somewhat but not quite
as much as if you had a commercial brand
the commercial brands are specially
designed
with additional emulsifiers
as well as
lipids that are going to really cause it
to foam more like cream than we have
here so it's not the greatest foamer but
it's certainly delicious and it's full
of fiber and beta glucans also it's
pretty abundant so it grows really well
in a lot of different places
soy milk has been around for a long time
it's first referenced in literature from
china in the 14th century it's the first
step in making tofu soy milk gained
popularity from the 80s when they moved
it from the center part of the grocery
store to the refrigerated section and
that's because that's where the dairy
milk is soy milk resembles bovine milk
pretty closely it's very high in protein
it has most of the essential amino acids
that we need in our diet to make the
proteins that we need in our bodies
just like cow's milk does let me show
you some of the similarities and
differences between soy and cow's milk
we have soy milk and we have
cow's milk if you were to look really
closely at the nutritional labels you
will find that cow's milk is higher in
fat per serving soy milk has about eight
grams of protein in an eight ounce
serving which is your typical serving of
any kind of milk it's also lowering
calories and it has some really good
nutritional benefits as well it's got
phytoestrogens as well as isoflavones
these are plant chemicals that are
associated with good health the other
thing is soy milk is part of the 2020 to
2025 dietary guidelines for americans
it's recommended in the dairy category
which is unique and very interesting the
reason it's there is because glass for
glass or serving for serving you're
going to have very comparable amounts of
protein
you can make rice milk from almost any
kind of rice commercially it's fortified
with other nutrients like b12 vitamin d
sometimes calcium one of the advantages
of rice milk is it does have a bit of a
whiter appearance and some people really
like that rice milk is great for people
with gluten sensitivity and that is
because it has no gluten
macadamia nuts make a fabulous milk this
plant-based milk tastes the most like
the nut which is extremely high in fat
in fact it's the fattiest nut that we
have on the market so a lot of the
flavor is translated into the milk
because a lot of the flavor compounds
are lipid soluble
hemp milk is from a seed it is really
becoming popular because like soy and
like cow's milk it's very high in
protein it also does not require a lot
of emulsifiers or additional chemicals
to give it shelf stability so you may
consider it to be slightly less
processed it's high in protein it's high
in fiber hemp is high in omega-3 fatty
acids which is an essential fatty acid
that means we have to take it in through
our diet our body doesn't make it itself
it's also very high in essential amino
acids they work the same way they're the
building blocks of the proteins that we
need for our metabolism so this little
tiny seed delivers a big nutrient
density hemp milk is really good for
people who want to avoid nuts or soy or
other allergens and as you can see it
has a pretty nice viscosity from that
omega-3 fatty acid
coconuts are one of the plants that are
very very high in fat whether or not
that translates into your coconut milk
depends on the packaging if you buy a
can of coconut milk it's got a lot of
fat in it and one of those fats is
called lauric acid it's a 12 carbon
fatty acid that is really important for
as an intermediary for forming other
biomolecules for human metabolism when
you buy coconut milk in the carton it's
going to be much thinner it's going to
be lower in fat lower in protein and
it's going to be slightly lower in
carbohydrates as well when you make
coconut milk at home you are not adding
any extra enzymes you're not any adding
any polysaccharides like gel and gum or
locust bean gum that you will find in
the commercial versions so this is just
as pure as it gets this homemade coconut
milk has so much complex coconut flavor
that you won't get from some of the
refined process in the commercial world
it also froths really nicely just in the
blender you can see i have a layer of
frothy foam so that the fats that were
leached out are really nicely emulsified
and they hold a really good foam
compared to some of the other
plant-based milks
pea milk does not taste like peas
ironically and that's because the
protein is isolated from the other
components in the yellow peas so you're
really just getting pure protein along
with water and some emulsifiers and
thickening agents as well it is made
differently than some of the other
commercial plant-based milks it's made
with yellow pea protein and the
manufacturers usually separate the fiber
and the starch from the protein and then
they use the protein powder in making
the milk pea protein you can actually
buy as a powder at the grocery store and
make your own that way
cashew milk is made with cashews they're
nice and white with isoflavones this
milk is fortified with vitamin b12 and
calcium cashew milk contains anacotic
acid which in one study showed to reduce
liver fat accumulation which can be
beneficial for type 2 diabetics
flaxseed is another plant-based milk on
the market as you can see it's a really
dark nutrient-dense tough little seed
flax seeds are also really high in
omega-3 and omega-6 fatty acids which
are essential for human metabolism so
this is really nutrient dense milk
flaxseed milk though sometimes has other
types of plant-based milk added to it
and that's to give it the protein
content or viscosity that you're looking
for in the final product
catalog milk is a grain-based milk
quinoa is called a super grain because
it's very high in protein so this is a
high protein high carb milk that's made
again by steeping the grain in water and
then filtering it
pistachio is the newest milk on the
market it just came to the grocery store
shelves in about 2020. so this is
something that you may see growing if
you open a pistachio you can see it's
beautiful green color as well as some
slight purple the green is from
chlorophyll it's lipid soluble and the
purple is from a compound called
anthocyanins and it's water soluble your
nut milks in particular are going to be
higher in fat when they're made at home
than they are commercially many
companies want to take the fat out of
the nut which also removes some of the
fat soluble vitamins and minerals and
they want to sell it it's a
higher
grossing product than the nut milk so
it's also a nice way to utilize the
entire nut
hazelnut milk also known as filberts
they're from a hazel tree usually when
you make hazelnut you take this outer
skin off because it's full of tannins
that can be a little bit astringent and
give you a little bit of a puckery
feeling in your mouth that you don't
want in your milk hazelnuts are also
really high in vitamin e similar to
almond milk you don't have a really
intense hazelnut flavor here but you do
get an essence of hazelnut so it pairs
really nicely with chocolate and you
might even call it a nutella plant-based
milk
[Music]
potato milk is one of the newest milks
on the market and in fact you can't even
get it in the united states yet it's
made by a company based in europe in
sweden and they take potatoes in a
proprietary process and cook all of the
starches out so that you're left with
just the potato protein it's becoming
really popular in european coffee shops
because it does foam so well it also has
a lower impact on the environment it
doesn't require quite as much water or
space it also is a nitrogen fixer so it
might not require as much fertilizer as
well i would think people find potato
milk to taste a little bit earthy kind
of like the potatoes that come from the
soil however i suspect it's more neutral
in taste because it's been so highly
refined and a lot of the compounds that
may impart any kind of flavor are likely
removed from the potato
banana milk is a fruit-based milk it's a
little thicker it's a little darker
from
enzymes an enzymatic reaction that you
have in bananas there's polyphenol
oxidase it's an enzyme that promotes
browning in certain fruits one of the
benefits of banana milk is that it's
usually fortified with vitamin b12
vitamin b12 is usually only delivered to
humans from animal sources banana milk
does not taste like bananas all of that
flavor has been removed in the
processing it has some of the thickness
from the starches in the bananas but it
does not have a banana flavor
sesame is a type of seed milk and it's
really high in oil sesame is a really
important seed crop in the world it's
grown in a lot of countries and for the
size there's quite a lot of oil which is
pressed out prior to making sesame milk
the oil is very valuable so you can sell
it for a higher price than the rest of
the seed sesame milk also usually
includes other types of plant-based
milks and emulsifiers and stabilizers
walnut milk is delicious it's made from
walnuts and it's pretty simple and
straightforward even commercially it's
very expensive because it's just walnuts
which are high in protein high in
essential fatty acids also have some
fiber in them and water so just those
very pure clean ingredients and you have
walnut milk
spelt milk is made from a grain that's
very small and it's an ancient grain
it's really high in protein and it has a
little bit of gluten proteins the gluten
and the gliadin that you find in wheat
so if you're avoiding any kind of gluten
you want to stay away from spilt
in conclusion there are many variations
and something for everybody out there
whether you want to go nuts seeds
cereals grains they're all delicious
they're nutrient dense and they make a
delicious plant-based milk